Benjamin Netanyahu had rarely if ever
looked publicly angrier than he did on
the 30th of May this year defeated in
his effort to form a coalition
government he prevented anyone else from
being given that chance by forcing
through an unprecedented election rerun
it's unbelievable
I adore Lieberman is now part of the
left the sense of betrayal was at his
former political fixer former foreign
and defense minister Ally and enemy for
more than 20 years
Avigdor Lieberman Lieberman's professed
reason for keeping his secular
right-wing party out of government was
his opposition to ultra-orthodox Jews
being exempted from military service
something that in yahoo's ultra-orthodox
political partners would not concede
Nurit Kedah
spent five years following Lieberman for
a documentary released this week finding
him a highly guarded interviewee but she
says it was clear that whatever the
ideological differences between him and
Netanyahu that divorce was deeply
personal the only thing the only
sentence that he said was that
friendship is something it's it's for
life you know it says some foundation
that it really go through all life and
it was broken and it was shattered the
woman hasn't explicitly ruled out
joining a Netanyahu led government this
time round but his policy demands make
it unlikely at best and with a secular
stance boosting his position in the
polls his status as kingmaker
has been strengthened Netanyahu has
spent the last week talking in terms
familiar from previous campaigns of
threats and promises the threat of
Iran's nuclear program the threat
requiring police at polling stations of
Palestinian Israeli voter fraud the
promise to annex the Jordan Valley and
parts of the occupied city of Hebron all
of it designed to motivate his
right-wing base the Netanyahu
re-election offers a better chance to
fight off three looming corruption cases
the Parliament or Knesset could even
vote to grant him immunity
but the poll suggests there could be a
similar outcome to last time with
Netanyahu's Likud Party running almost
even with the opposition blue and white
led by former army chief Benny Ganz
there's a good chance neither will have
enough support from smaller parties to
piece together a majority coalition some
predict months more uncertainty while
each side tries and fails to form a
government increasing the pressure on
Netanyahu his indictment is expected to
happen in the first half of December
that would be during the second period
of six weeks in which a candidate would
be given a chance to form a government
and if then indictment happens then the
leak could will then realize okay we
don't like overthrowing leaders but now
we have no choice
Israel's second election in five months
is unlikely to be the finish line in the
contest to govern the country rather the
starting gun for the next round in the
fight
Harry Fawcett al Jazeera West Jerusalem